should be live how's it going everyone
today I'm playing some blitz faster
chess let's preserve this guy
it is super blitz shield arena and I
just realized I left
Demitri on let me turn them off we're
going into one of my favorite variations
against players of weaker level a lot of
people will Castle here and walk into
the great gift which happens that's nice
it's a great reason to play this line
against the French Queen h5 I've shown
countless students this exact line after
rook e8 there's force mates maybe it
will happen the only move to avoid force
made this Queen take g5 or Bishop take F
2 and then Queen take g5 do I wanna play
now I can get away with this
Queen b6 and maybe just like King III
alright King when I sign King g3 no more
checks may this coming if rip da they
take on f7 first this is very pleasant
it's a good start not sure why it took
me 40 seconds to get to this position
you guys are just playing slowly but ok
he'll think I'll take here he's sacking
everything trying to get out of mates
but it's not working
maybe Queen e3 next or queen f2
do guess the move okay Nathan - okay
that was a really nice start back to
tournament I moved up a couple hundred
places a new game will be zerk again the
goal is to get to the top ten within
like 90 minutes
you look so ominous when your room is
all dark
my room is not dark it's pretty light
but the window is open and it's sunny
and just the lighting effect makes it so
it looks dark in the background but I
guess it's just exposure compensation
this guy hung a knight that's really
nice of him and people are so generous
today
oh do i do I just develop develop more
Bishop d6 looks weird but Miley bishops
most likely going to be seven we'll take
this and take our niche - if she hello
hello Steve stir let's do it subdued
there should be five so now it's just a
matter of playing quickly and converting
the extra piece extra piece and extra
pawn I think the strategy is just to
develop the pieces
I forgot c3 is hanging I could take it
with the bishop to Ben Queen c2 and then
rook c8 okay it's good enough hello
shark bay chess what does this mean Eric
only accept challenges from friends I
turned off challenges from all people
because it was getting to be a bit too
much and today I'm just playing the
blitz shield arena so
I won't be accepting challenges but if
you want the chance to play me I guess
you could join the tournament no
guarantee there's over a thousand people
in this tournament right now
hello Meat Boy soup interesting username
like take on f3 take on the three I
think that works cuz I'm threatening
mate and then if he takes back
I win d3 with check if she could play
queen f2 ooh
enough to Knight g4 some nice tactics
going on and then I teach to check I
really have to watch my time if I'm busy
working I kind of forgot I better at
this game
luckily I'm up a ton of material putting
another pod will just probably push the
H pawn the quickest way to win or maybe
your xe2
active rook Bishop d3 coming my queen g3
or queen H - wait where's the mate
bishop f1 Queen h4 somehow he's
surviving I'll probably castle him bring
my other rook in I'm threatening Queenie
v which is force mates but your voice
it's maybe still Queen e5 how is he
surviving this for so long
okay the other rook is coming in he's
not going to survive much longer
oh that was a free rook but I'm low on
time I just have to convert it's plenty
of time he survived longer than expected
okay hello excise sparks it's going well
and hello
Sanjeev just saw Thea and hello the
fucsia good to see you all and thanks
for the follow a meat boy soup I'm
looking at us right now it does look a
little bit ominous but it's like stage
lighting I think this is actually decent
lighting I'm not gonna desert this game
and play you for hello certain men SC
what do I want to do let's play some
scotch gambit I started playing this
maybe about a week ago and realize it's
a good way to try and beat lower rated
players quickly black to climb the
gambit now white just has a pleasant
position play g4g for looks interesting
maybe slightly overextending but White
has good development f6 is not a great
move he probably should have played in
97 cuz now it's a bit weakening for
black so 95 I take kil retreats
each five interesting maybe now I can
take on e5 and then take on each five
though it's not winning anything because
you can trade Queens so let's throw in a
check I don't want the Queen trade
because this King should be less safe
than mine
but maybe not I have rook t1 here but
then Queen b6 mm-hmm like b4 b4 Bishop
t4 I don't quite like what I've done
with the position h5 doesn't do much
Oh f2 is defended so I could allow Queen
b6 be three okay
it spent too much time there oh do I
have 95 here does 95 just crushing
Knight g5 Queens AP 297 let's got to be
good I don't even see 95 supply per move
you should probably see if you play rook
do you want but ok now he's in trouble
because his queen can't move anywhere
good to the fence e7 she moves back to
d8 I didn't I take our six winning the
Queen um you could throw in some check
no he can't
throw in a check you could try and take
on b2 it's probably the messiest line
but then they see 7 anyway and then when
I take the rook he'll get like 1 check
at 19 s1 and white should be safe and
just upper rook can you protect b6
square with the night I think that's
what's happening but instead of
protecting b6 I'm attacking these
why automat oh I'm I apologize something
from the fukes yeah being profiled by
autumn on okay will win the bishop now
White's up a piece I'm gonna bring the
Knights oh and I see two is a bad move
oh my gosh not paying attention this is
a really bad move
losing back my piece to play this okay I
got distracted by the fucsia and
although mod it's not good I have to
retreat White's just down like a bunch
of pawns now that's what happens if you
get distracted and blitz bad things
happen I'm still gonna try and win this
because my rooks are coordinated rugby
sevens coming this Rick's kind of stuck
white is down to pawns but maybe I can
win b7 rookie Jade is a good sign
his Knights passive I should win at
least a pawn here if he plays rook b8 I
think I have rook c7 and then rook DD 7
so I don't think you can trap this rook
in time yeah counter play
okay so we can trade and I'll take on v7
take on g7 okay I can breathe easy now
this is h4 probably winning another pawn
or two pawns I don't want to trade rook
so let's play rook here well maybe we
have to trade at some point but black
stuck like I'd rather leave him just
kind of stuck this pawn now dominate
some nights you know that's like very
very stuck let's take on a six pick on
c6 I went from being down two pawns to
up two pawns that's nice
about three pumps that was a great time
for that song let's see if we have the
moobot command if someone wants to type
in the command push him baby
it should link to the song because I'm
just gonna start pushing pawns even my
dog is excited keep pushing keep pushing
I'm not even trying to like beat him
slowly I'm just trying to be efficient
okay not the cleanest game I should not
have allowed Bishop take 4 but that's
life that splits okay you see Steven one
rook to e1 double question mark move the
knight play f3 and trapping bishop I
didn't consider that but that's an
interesting idea I should have
considered that I would just have to
make sure the bishop is getting trapped
she probably is
you played that opening to be this guy
quickly yeah that was a that was a long
game okay let me try and focus not look
at the chat too much g3 g3 is best met
with d5
I know this is supposed to be equalizing
he just wants to trade queens let's play
nine of six at least get the knight in
the center you might play Bishop g2 here
yeah um I could take I guess wait no I
don't want to take his Queens ridiculous
on f3 oh let's move
I want to go with my queen I'm just
gonna move back to d8 and argue that his
Queens more misplaced I just want to
play next c6 next maybe 94 maybe Bishop
g4 ideas if b7 is opinion it's lady 5e
four possibilities no it's playing
strangely okay I'm just gonna develop
develop and play quickly play each six
preventing Bishop g5 so now he wants to
play 94 which is a move I'm just gonna
keep developing we can take up in here
attack the pond very soon I'll probably
look to play c4 like right now because I
want a better square for this bishop
maybe there's some positional play the
queen e7 Bishop c5 maybe pawn store and
get the rook to d8 now if we trade the
darts for bishops and he's left with a
bad Bishop and I have a good Bishop rook
g1 was best because after f3 he takes
one g4 yeah I just didn't consider
allowing him to take the rook thanks for
the follow virtual squid okay trip d8
the D file is very important in this
position I don't know if I can take over
the defiled life force f5 looks scary
but let's just do stuff on the Queen
side okay Queenie three
I think I'm flying with the Queen trade
I like my pieces better than his pieces
I'm playing 97 maybe to pop into f4 this
is Bishop so pad there might be some
situations where I trade off my Bishop
for his Knights like a situation like
this I might take oh no I won't take
next move because it opens up his bishop
maybe in the future we can trade Bishop
four Knights
it's just not night for a bishop might
be three on the horizon utilizing some
some weak squares it's just improve baby
now I double up ooh
95 mm-hmm
how do I double up and not get forked
probably this move I don't know if rook
87 won't do anything cuz his Knight is
supported by the bishop he actually
found a use for the bishop in this
position but I just want to build up
pressure b3 it's possible move we could
trade might get like rook e1 ideas I'm
thinking maybe I have 94 here I'll put
rookie fives coming uh what to do okay
let's do this let's try and undermine
the Queen side when in doubt go for pawn
breaks it takes really let's play f5
more pawn Greeks now there's some idea
yeah the idea was to take and planing
before now I have a super Knights and
his bishop still kind of stuck yeah my
pawns just block out the bishop I have
this move I have that move in this move
this is so nice wants to play h6 just
flaking h7 oh this is so amazing like
that bishop it's so depressing sad monk
78 thanks for the follow okay we're
gonna try it just to meet him on e1 is
that Force mate that might be force
mates i he can't stop it
Wow such a nice finish that was some
nice positional chess like his bishop
was just a bad piece the whole game it
almost got active but luckily this saw
this whole mechanism with like h5 and
then f5 I think was very important
okay well berserk this game can play
before
try and beat this guy quickly it's plank
c5 will play one of my favorite lines
Grand Prix attack I haven't really been
looking at the chat oh thanks X I sparks
for sharing the push and baby
commands from previous game basics all
prevent b5 hello dark are in damn
welcome Bishop c4 I have a sneaky threat
please play g6 ok he didn't will Castle
if you play g6 I had bishop take f7 in
that g5 Knight d4 slightly annoying but
what to do let's just continue
developing if he takes on that three I
have to take back with G pawn and the
pawn structure looks if he for whites
but blacks not developed
I would like to strike in the center
let's start with Queen g3 try and soften
some some of the structure on the King
side for black f5 looks very very
attractive f5 you can take twice in the
eye when g7 I'm forking this in this and
thanks for the follow dark are and damn
I know if I said that correctly but
thanks anyways yeah he's losing one of
these things Bishop f6 would be a nice
move he actually can't defend you like
he can't save the rook you could defend
the pawn to that I win the rook Eric who
will the candidates who will win the
candidates I think if she means I take
the bishop first mmm take the rook first
who will win the candidates I mean I'm
kind of rooting for Carmona who was
thrown a check I'll win the night well I
berserk this game I completely forgot
okay I need to change though of each a
settings to give me a time warning more
quickly
we'll just trade Queens and then White's
upload Brooking at night the strategy is
to get the rooks to the seventh as
quickly as possible
yeah I have no idea who will win the
candidates I knew who I'm rooting for
like Caruana or Wesley but I think it's
gonna be very close I wouldn't be
surprised if like three or four players
are in contention going into the last
round alright we could have some
exciting finish this is Rosen's crazy
opening I mean it's not too crazy it's
more controlled than some other openings
I play
you should try Zen mode press the Z do I
want to do that with 17 seconds left um
what do I do you stop for a g7 I feel
stuck that Bishop on s6 is annoying okay
I have to start moving quickly you start
pre moving rook b6 will come ooh some
meaning ideas
maybe not force mates but it's very
close yeah truck c7 coming we can trade
King c6 is not me let's walk my king up
five seconds is plenty of time should be
plenty of time okay
good game hey I didn't have to use more
than the more than one second there okay
back to tournaments Oh proceed I don't
think it works does it work during a
game right it only works during the game
okay well that's good to know I still
don't know what that does though I'll
try it at the beginning of next game
press easy Oh interesting
mmm-hmm do you guys like that I don't
know I'm used to the other layouts let
me know what you guys prefer okay I'm
gonna play e6 and be solid we'll play g5
here no no okay
yeah I wasn't a huge fan so this guy
gives me the bishop pair when your
opponent gives you the bishop pair so
early it's usually best to open the
position but now there's tension I'm
gonna take once I think the rule is very
supposed to take once and then what's
castle
I might take twice if he moves his
bishop oh he wants to attack me it's not
very nice okay well all play Knight c6
but he plays Bishop d3 then I take oh he
wants to greet gift me does that
actually work if I take bishop take h7
take my g5 f king h6 sir
Queen d2 hmm might get away with
something there I could play h6 it's
just by age six safe move g4 he really
wants to kill me but now I can take like
if your opponent tries to kill you on
the side you're supposed to respond in
the center another chest principal D
force hanging now yeah let's just true
let's take and we'll trade a bunch of
things if he plays g5 I take and then
take them I should survive that or do I
take looks okay
because now h5 I just want to close
files on the kingside Queen c7 looks
fine so blocks of a pawn Kings
relatively safe Queen b3 I'll throw in
the check any Queen's rate would be good
for luck if you place King f1 I'll
probably go for B 656 anyway
preparing bishop a 6-quart Bishop e7
that bishops defended but the queen is
overworked I can win this pawn oh but
then the h5 parkings let's play g6 ok
I'm happy with the Queen trade I'm also
happy winning upon win the pawn be
greedy okay so now blocks up two pawns
King is still safe still takes a little
bit of work something knowing move I
don't think it does anything though does
it do anything
okay this I'm hoping for a rook d7 does
that okay this looks okay Queen f6 Queen
c7 this is actually a classic like a
game situation with especially a queen
ending if I have the majority here I'll
just make a passer and my king safe that
he can't perpetual check me I'll just
put my Queen on b7 and then start
pushing pawns any Queen trade is winning
for luck
whoa
I have to move quicker again I figure
out that time it's just force a'queen
trade somehow the Queen c2 at some point
I'm throwing g8 so this is defended
okay nb2
there's no check on the eights there's
one check on the it's okay
and now the two queens are decisive cool
there's a stream hanging or is it my net
let me know if they slag hopefully
there's not Internet seems to be good on
my side
hey I'm top 200 okay moving up I'm not
gonna desert this game let's play a
dragon if he loves me
he's mainline dragon I'll see what he
does
hmm he's going for Yugoslavia cyl be fun
G for so early I think I just develop I
actually don't know theory here all I
know is like if they bought you you can
put the bishop on e6 and it's a happier
piece and if he plays h4 I play h5 let's
stop any um breakthrough he's playing
quickly I might just want to trade
Queens like take on g4 in Queen b6 this
is very common with like Sicilian
positions any Queen trait should favor
back so now from a positional standpoint
it's so pleasant like my nice very good
I'm ready to play King g7 rookie chaydez
and meanwhile I don't know what he's
doing like this bishop especially is not
a great piece
thanks for the follow Pat drown eating
I'm okay he wants to trade nights that's
a reasonable plan I guess we could trade
I didn't want to trade mm-hmm
I guess I have to and oh he wants to
play f5 so ambitious but I can take the
pawn replays that five I think I can I
can I take on e4 oh this looks fun it
might be slightly dubious but I'm gonna
do it
yes Bishop d3 here yeah and then I take
there and this is what I saw it I
couldn't resist is now I have three
connected passers and it's a great time
for that song so they push him baby song
and so many past pawns
I'll play this I think he's losing
another pawn now because b5 attacked the
pinned upon now I have four connected
passers
this is way too fun I don't want to take
that or do I let's throw in the check if
the King moves to the third rank I broke
d3 well I might just meet him yeah if he
gets too feisty with the King whoa is
that even a move I guess that's the move
I can win another pawn what is this move
f6 doesn't quite work I could just
defend everything will take rooks e7 e 6
that's actually kind of annoying
okay we'll take the fun I have a bishop
in five points for a rook it's a lot of
pawns I still need to prove the position
though let's play you six I don't care
about maybe Khan yeah that can go Bishop
f5 everything defended very soon we'll
start pushing probably the D pawn will
be the first one to get going if he
plays King g6 okay yeah there's just a
line that I wasn't entirely sure about
but it's okay but he could try this in
this but then their systems and
meanwhile there's this
don't fly yeah I'm managing my time get
ready to push that fun oh he can take on
ud3 that's okay I can afford to lose
that this is still completely winning
and when you have the bishop you want to
make sure the pawns are going on dark
space so then the bishop can control the
lights ways I guess you swung this sort
of situation if I had two pawns this
would probably be a draw three pawns is
enough play this
maybe I just broke my own rule but this
should be good this Kings stuck I want
to play you three next mm-hmm how do I
make progress oh I can play III that's a
threat
okay just enough time maybe not the best
conversion but good game that was a fun
position okay another game we'll play
another dragon I was a good experienced
crew 64 come on
d4 d3 don't [ __ ] okay ah Bishop c4 we'll
play you 6 oh I meant to do this earlier
but congratulations 364 you've earned
yourself the mod title don't abuse it ok
I'll try and play quicker this game yeah
last game I wasn't really paying
attention to time is that a move my g4
maybe not the best move definitely not
the best move ok we're gonna go into
some sort of French structure you might
force me back to h6 or do that well now
my bishops are very happy we could play
h5 let's play h5 no reason to calculate
mmm it should be very fun if he takes my
Knights
it should also be fun if he doesn't take
my Knights
and the plan here is to over carefully I
want you to Castle queenside somehow mmm
I wanted to play f6 but then rotate u6
what to do I'm just gonna unleash this
monster on b7 and may be preparing
casting queenside my Knights still
hanging you can still take it but he
wants to trade that's not fun mmm okay
we'll play positional I'm okay with this
there's this maneuver 95 94 93 and still
some attack and my pieces will start to
coordinate somehow hopefully
mm okay 904 I didn't see that
that's a scary move I have to retreat
it's still okay looks a little bit risky
though this looks very very basic uh-oh
this is really bad Queen f3 happens I'm
losing something and losing a piece
because that's a fork I don't wanna play
95 cuz Queen take f7 uh I'm gonna have
to fight this was bad at least she's
sort of low in time how did that go
wrong I think I just didn't I should
have moved my rook somewhere I forgot
Queen f3 was a good mood but okay he's
1800 uh I'm okay trading Queens make the
game lasts longer but their work on g5
and now the strategy is just to move
quickly and hopefully eventually flaggin
just not give him any breakthrough but
when I do work age six maybe
this is not the the game that I
preferred to play or down a piece and
have to flag the guy but you got to do
what you got to do f5 is an interesting
idea but let's ignore it with some idea
to go for this before break knight c6
could be annoying though oh never mind
yeah just a lot of moving around
hello to odd non chess how's it going
King g6 will attack the C pawn Oh that
night it's very very passive it will win
the seat on f6 restrict the knight take
the knight taking the Ripper's probably
winning but let's just win pawns
okay now they're good game but that's
life I broke into the top hundred I'm
not going to be able to stay for this
whole tournament there's three hours
left
Wow let's brick this game I want to
climb up a bit quicker
what does that move let's play the
London I'm gonna play the London against
k-6
just an easy setup to play play a four
if he buys before there's a knight c4
which is nice that's nice you for here -
and g6 as a whole if he plays d5 I have
95 you could do that I'll take with me
pawn g6 is still a whole that's logical
but I can do this mmm okay no
breakthrough complete development and
castle play some client moves I keep
having to remind myself that I preserve
this game so if I forget please remind
me I'm gonna drop the Queen back to c2
and target h7 and maybe even go for like
Knight g5 at some points like Knight g5
could be a very menacing threat g6 is
probably a good move
thanks for the follow Sherlock 1 1 7
Queen z2 very important move to prevent
age six um but maybe it doesn't do that
much it's late there's bad for playing
Bishop c2 I want to put the bishop on a
for he takes okay take with pollen no
but we'll take with Knight keep the
space and now Bishop a4 mmm maybe you
can get away with taking yeah because he
has makes you for in between move I
still like the position because this
bishops terrible let's go for g3 h4
stuff well leave the tension between the
bishops thank you chess player
appreciate the follow yeah I just want
to like pawn storm its play h4 and
whiskey thank you
I don't think I said that correctly
before maybe not the best move but I'll
play rookie 3 C 3 will be defended and I
just want to attack on the Kings side
but 27 seconds left ok so I have a
faster pace here put the King on each
three where maybe it supports some g4
break who I have an idea I'm gonna try
and sack on h5 that doesn't work and he
has 85 check it's not nice uh what do I
do I have to move faster he's low on
time too which is good maybe Bishop b3
more active square Bishop a4 no I didn't
want to do that no that's for ok close
the position 16 seconds left
I wanted to play Bishop III okay I'm
gonna go for Queen h3 force the Queen
trade and then as crew 64 would say I'm
in the cocoon until he Flags cacoon
cacoon and then trick him like that
except I'm losing asleep on know I know
is he meeting me no I didn't cocoon
correctly I lost the pawn oh that's so
disappointing
I shouldn't have is ripped I mean yeah
that's rough
oh crew sexy force playing to was
working every game the first loss life
is tough chess is tough but what can you
do
my opponent played well to survive like
his position was worse
I'm not slipped Bishop a4 I still should
have won let's not buzzer Kenny morning
let's go back to some quieter chess oh
no I'm not I withdrew like one and a
half hours ago um well I guess I caught
it I caught up to 360 for them is we
have about the same score please play 97
please or night ft-7 okay we'll take
wait what's the move here I forget the
move
maybe g3 when the Queen goes to e to the
bishop goes to G - who cares only one
loss one losses a lot of losses okay
double fee and care though against the
caro-kann not the most common setup for
whites
that's a move let's play Queen back to
you - I was thinking about casting queen
side but if he's gonna play a five I'll
be safe a four okay we'll play in the
center maybe go for f4 his bishops not
great my both my bishops are so happy
right now what do I want to do let's
play f4 I'm not used to having my bishop
on me - it's like a crew 64 Bishop I
forgot like there's all this pressure on
the diagonal maybe go for g4 g5 she's
essentially down at peace the bishop on
see it maybe I'll just be cheap and play
this move and maybe he won't see the
threats actually if he does he see the
threats or if he doesn't see the threat
it doesn't even work
it's Bishop a5 26 and there's a pin it's
kind of annoying I can't win anything
okay I'm gonna be persistent here let's
try and get in Bishop a5 please don't
see it Queen e1 and defending the rook
so there's no pin oh he saw it's okay it
will play h3 slow play I'll take the
bishop yeah he has to take back with
pawn that's a good sign
activate the rook maybe go for g4 g5 was
one of my initial plans but then he is
mighty 5f5 looks attractive here because
this pawn is pinned and now it's
attacked twice might win upon mmm I'm
very tempted to take him d7 and then
take on e6 but I like my book now my
rooks gonna swing over and participates
King crusher leading the tournament King
crusher applause the tournament
interesting okay so rook g4 he plays g6
mmm f6
okay that's that looks amazing g6 f6
Bishop d6 Queen e3 I'll try and me the
money six if he doesn't play g6 what
else to do if you could play f6 then I
take the pawn
yeah it's nice to have like all your
time to start the game not the zurk how
does he stop this she's mighty son r97
Bishop f8 slightly annoying okay I'm
gonna move my truck back I'm still
threatening this Bishop a5 move and he
didn't see it I don't know if it's that
good for me cuz will win the half 6 pawn
does win the exchange
ok we'll take on c6 then you go for work
aids in some cases yeah I'm just gonna
move quickly it's a winning position for
whites but the quickest way to win will
be winning on time thank you sir John Oh
dying for the follow
please just flag oh let's do this
tack the pins Knights okay thank you a
good game I like that opening the double
fee and cadeaux and that caro-kann line
I don't think it's a super popular
Sabbath but it's something oh and it's a
cheer flocking Mora 400 bits
Cruz wait what does that say crew 64
something through 64 alts with many many
T's I don't even know what that means
well thank you anyway
Joshua Phillips something mathematics
thanks for the follow I'm gonna try and
play a dragon c3 okay so delayed c3
Sicilian I do apologize I haven't really
been looking at the chats it's very hard
to look at the chat and play blitz but
maybe I missed something
diagnose anything if I missed anything
just repeat yourself
it's my alt account Eric oh it's his alt
account
[ __ ] Maura wait what I'm so confused
okay we're gonna take the pawn
and queens Yates this is a very boring
opening the hopefully things will get
more interesting later our and um chess
guy thanks for the follow and goozle on
nine I keep getting distracted as so
many people are following but this is a
simple position to play like black just
wants to okay we might trade bishops but
black just wants to get rooks to like D
agency aides and I forgot who told me
this I only learned this recently but
apparently if you have a queen site
minority against the Queen side my
majority it slightly favors the minority
because I can try and induce weaknesses
later
MOTU man just donated $5 thank you so
much that's like a it's one of the first
donations I've ever exceeds I think
that's the third donation ever I do
appreciate that and people are so
generous today on an off the board
okay well play Queen c7 get away from
any attack also preventing Bishop f4 so
there's some idea of 95 and this Bishop
is kind of awkward and it's a type of
position like it looks very equal maybe
somewhat Josh but there's lots of
opportunities to try and I'll play the
opponent it was yeah I just want to like
trade-off might for Bishop or just leave
his Bishop like being awkward guess he
could play Bishop c1
but then I'll improve that rooks okay
we'll take and this is what I want just
some more more imbalances the the Bishop
versus Knight scenario should favor it
favors the bishop when there's pawns on
both sides of the board for this try and
stay calm we could trade a pair of
Brooks if it takes with Queen I wouldn't
be too and now see for is actually
pretty weak
the 92 forced 92 plus b5 work b5 take
Queen c1 right F 1 I want to do
something but maybe the trick is to do
nothing and just improve wait what
should I do here okay here's the one
time I'm just gonna like create some
moved h6 now the one thing I don't want
to trade I don't want to trade the other
pair of Brooks because then Queen and
Knight is supposed to be better than
Queen and Bishop
so the keep rooks on the board b5 looks
very strong now amend this oh no
someone's facetiming me who's facetiming
me I was a weird it just popped up and
then it said miss call if someone in the
chat tried to FaceTime me let me know
who you are okay but let's focus on this
position it should just be crushing but
maybe not keep all the tension when your
opponent slow in time you want to keep
as much tension as possible in the
position
but now I don't know I'm also a long
time let's play trip to yet take a three
oh yeah we can trade put the bishop on
b2 and then flag him
I feel battling winning most of my games
by flogging the opponents but I mean
it's blitz
that's a fork okay
good game I think that was an
instructive like kind of situation kind
of varied Josh seemingly Josh opening
but still lots of room for dynamic play
behave chat was a chat misbehaving oh
people are just leaving I have to get
back to work come on hop back okay well
thank you guys who were watching but
then left I hope you enjoyed I'm black
again we'll play another Sicilian I
forgot to mention though like if anyone
wants me to play a certain opening I
guess I'll take opening recommendations
for the next game then hopefully I'll be
widen that in the next game so if anyone
wants to see a white opening let me know
I'm going for this line with h5 so it's
a pet line maybe not objectively the
best but it should be playable
95 looks very weird but it's a very
typical move even though I create the
pin
I'll have d6 in the future like right
now as bishops not exactly that great ah
ah ah ah 3o Braden's in the chat Josh
opening more equal game yeah Oh equal
games with like small advantages are
great I do apologize to Braden because I
was watching I was watching your stream
yesterday and I was in the chat and you
asked me some question and then I
disappeared because I got a phone call
and the phone call like took a long time
and then then I was walking the dog and
I just like wasn't watching like I just
had to leave and like too many things
were happening at once
I forget what you asked me it was
something about Windows but I don't know
no uh no harm intended okay he just hung
a nice Wow I mean people have been
generous to me but that's uh I was a
very nice gift this guy should get like
a stream notification for just donating
a night so nice of him ok let's try and
kill him quickly I'm gonna play my g5
mmm Bishop to g5 ok we'll play Knight g5
I'm just envisioning some like funny
checkmates like if we trade bishops and
I have my H 3 and s 4 oh he wants to
kill me
taketake wait
linkie for us a good move I counter
talked the rook and I'm preparing a
three canal Schwimmer
what about caro-kann if I'm black again
I'll play Carol Kahn if my opponent
plays before were there any other
suggestions he 4605 wait what I am going
to prioritize real openings so if anyone
wants to suggest a real opening and that
was not referring to Carol Carol Kahn is
a real opening he's referring to someone
suggesting French me five on move - okay
I'm gonna do this and then rook age six
he takes with pawn play Queen a5
checkmating ideas I don't know what this
does I think I'm preparing Bishop h4
which probably does something Steinitz
attack okay I have to look into that
Queen f5 I can take my bishop wait
what's the Volga gambit I miss any other
recommendations please explain the Volga
gambit never heard of that
okay good game actually was my day for
maybe not the best game okay I have like
a half hour more to play climbing up
57th place okay we're playing the
highest rated opponent so far
okay well I'll play e4 because someone
suggested this opening like II 6 and
then II 5 but he plays d5 ok well play
Scandinavian
nine of six well we'll try and be
principal Bishop e5 is the principled
move and Bishop c4 uh it seems like he's
in some sort of Theory a3 looks
reasonable and seems like using very
deep in theory he wants to win back the
pawn okay I'm just gonna develop you use
some intuition here you just put sing
out everything
maybe d4 first yeah d4 I can't complain
with this position you won back the pawn
but White has some development Oh Castle
next this f3 move is kind of weird but
if you ever plays Bishop e7 f 3 is
actually a useful pawn undermining the
Bishop f3 also facilitates some kind of
Queen e1 Queen g3 stuff c5 interesting
play King H 1 F 3 is theory there's only
one line I know that's when black plays
85 instead of Bishop g4 and I actually
have a novelty in that line like really
cool
maybe not novelty but a really cool idea
yeah I'll go for some King side attack I
don't know how effective an attack will
be here
but I don't know there's some resources
we need three is a resource Bishop g5 or
Bishop h6 stuff I might want to focus in
the center - I'm gonna start with rook
do you want max ray vision against the
Queen well I had 96 - which I kind of
forgot about I don't know if that's a
great move he wants to play a four also
bishop a six can be really annoying he
may have had Bishop a six last move
threatening my knight in threatening c4
okay I have to use some intuition here
Knight do I do
gonna play Knight f4 there's so much
tension here okay we'll trade some stuff
b6 this looks like a nice move Bishop a4
Bishop should be more useful there and
the knight is pinned
I take take take
[Music]
I have to move quicker we'll trade and
do this
I forget the pawn to e5 it should be
pretty Pleasant but I just have to move
much quicker spending too much time
there thank you for the follow Bradley
triple underscore h4 attack I just want
to make him think someone calling me a
slowpoke crew 64 calling me a slowpoke
I mean take no it doesn't work yeah I'm
I'm pretty slow today I don't know why
that doesn't work either it's for h6 I'm
slow and I'm weak it's not like a
combination I'm losing so many pawns at
least the H files open sort of we're not
going to trade Queens
that was a good move this is stressful
efore is a nice square for the night but
we have to trade defense e2 that might
be a pawn for free
oh he pinned me no stop it oh my gosh
this is bad ah truck beds Oh No Oh
that was so sad I am slow oh I was
trying to prove crew 64 wrong but change
from tea to coffee that's a good idea
I had caffeinated tea but it's not
enough caffeine that guy played well
what did I do wrong
I did many people's wrong nothing I
don't know what to look up that opening
though I also want to share I'm just
gonna give away a novelty like I've I
think I've only used it once dad use it
once against it was very recent it's an
amazing opening trick though like if if
you're running into the Scandinavian
mine I'm black play slightly differently
so
this Knight f6 move well me chess we
just should not make the down arrow go
to the end of the game that's just a
request because i always accidentally
press the down arrow anyway
if you're white you play e4 you're
probably gonna get to this position at
some points where they play a knight of
six and they don't take with the queen
the best move at least in my opinion the
most challenging move to play as Bishop
e5 check if you're just trying to refute
the opening and probably just uh yeah
just like a good advantage for white if
you're well-prepared um no there's a few
moves for black most common is Bishop d7
then Bishop c4 the whole idea is you
provoke Bishop d7 you defend the pawn
lock has to work to win the pawn back no
the move my opponent played was b5 it's
actually a secondary line but we'll
focus on that d5 it should be three now
this is what I was prepared for I was
hoping he would play is this move a5
because now White has a really cool idea
where oh it's been played many times
let's move a4 but there's an idea which
maybe is more rare where after a four
black will take yeah and oh it's not a
novelty but the the least common move
here is actually the best move is to
take on a4 with the rook and it looks
like dubious it looks like just a thing
that you might play in blitz but it's
actually just the best move and the
whole point is that if black wins
exchange which they will inevitably do
there's massive massive compensation and
I had this other day maybe it was even
yesterday against a little Potkin and he
he allowed this and but somehow he Flags
me because it was hyper bullet so I was
unfortunate but just to demonstrate 97
way can play Knight f3
and then let's say block tries to
develop like g6 like this is the most
natural way to develop and then try and
castle whites attack comes very quickly
95 Bishop g7 and then knight c6 McQueen
only has one square c8 and then the
problem for luck is he can't castle
because ninety-seven look forth the king
and queen and a move here like c4 this
black is almost paralyzed Queen e2 is
coming so just a cool line to know for
whites its most importantly starting
with with Bishop b5 check after knight
Knight f6 so I'll leave it but I'll
leave it at bats let's go back to the
tournament wait no I wanted to see what
I did wrong in the game though uh
getting carried away here Bishop g4 okay
secondary move f3
Bishop c8 is there what's the advantage
for whites stockfish so I played Knight
c3 he played B 494 so maybe it was just
a good position might d4 here nothing
wrong with that yeah maybe just a small
edge I just had to manage my time better
Oh c4 interesting idea take and then
take the pawn okay I'll keep that in
mind for the future let's go back to the
tournament
so I have two losses so far I'm still on
the top hundred not the easiest
tournament so I just lose a chat oh no I
think I closed out of the chat window so
I don't know what people are saying or
no do I have it open we're gonna go oh I
still have it open okay
it was just hiding okay B 6 what is B 6
let's play 9 3 I'm gonna treat this like
over Bruce Larson where if he plays east
6 I'm gonna play e5 and then I'll make
whoever suggested that what was the call
to Stein it's attack or whatever against
the French he's playing g6 let's play h4
and I'm ok with this h5 weakens g5 so
Bishop g5 will probably come at some
points Bishop g7 Bishop g5 Bishop g5
anyway oh he wants to play a hippo but
he can't play a hippo because my bishop
signs you fine that's nice I'm gonna
play a 4 because a 5 will be annoying
for him so I'm expecting a 5 but it's
nice to just make him think I play d5
here you thought I have my g5 maybe e6
let's do it
I'm playing very aggressive this game
but hopefully it pays off somehow
ok we'll take
because I just want to play e6 I want to
sack a pawn I forgot about that move
though I don't think that should work
though because he takes on e5 at Bishop
b5 check there's gonna be some
compensation
hopefully massive compensation thinking
if he plays Knight d7 I'll just take on
g7 it seems bad like when you're pinning
a piece you don't want to take it but he
liked his Queens tied down so he can't
take with Queen because it's defending
the rook I could just play Queen Oh
Queen d5 looks crushing wait Queen g5 c
6 will be accurate here
she wants to play c6 next yeah I'm gonna
take it usually you should not take a
pin piece like this but the whole point
is that it's very concrete's he has to
take with nights and then Queen c6 and
he can't escape with any move like like
c6 and he's just completely stuck and
I'm ready to bring my rook to d1 and the
Knights pin the pawns pinned queenside
castling is coming followed by brooke
he1 it reminds me of the position that I
was just showing like where white sac
the exchange and the black King was
stuck in the center here are whites just
down upon but yeah it's just crushing I
even have like 95 ideas I can allow him
to capture on c3 man I was imagining if
the bishop still on f8 I would have rook
e1 94 96 mates with a double pin but
okay that's only a fantasy
can I take I think I can take then rook
H e1 take on d7 yeah when you're when
your pieces are so good you can afford
to sacrifice it's just so fun okay
well that was a feel-good game like he
tried to play the hippo he was going for
a hippo but I think h4 is a great move -
trying to stir hippo cuz once he commits
to h5 like he can't achieve this like
setup that he wants the structure so
that was fun a seventy first place what
does the leader have wow this guy's
crushing it from Indonesia
I wonder if I play him I wasn't it I was
in Indonesia like two months ago and the
internet there could be better but good
job to him okay
oh we're white again I'll play you for
again I'll try and get a new opening Oh
Karel count okay we'll play the what is
this six
we'll play d4 you be be aggressive
maybe f4 f4 makes sense here okay I
shouldn't take time let's start with
Bishop to e3 I know my bishop wants to
go to t3 I don't know if I Pauling wants
to go to f4 I'm just gonna play Knight
to f3 Castle I think I can take there
chef III I think this is okay if he
takes one b2 I had Knight d5 if he does
that I have Knight d5 still and this is
major threat and this is basically just
over not the best opening from black cuz
I'm winning a 7 if King g7 i Bishop e5
oh what's the best way to proceed I can
take a 7 whenever I want I'm gonna start
with Bishop e5 if he plays Queen c7 it's
meats if he plays Queen b6 there's b4
and this is nice life is good I'm nights
hanging a7 singing this is probably a
good time for that to end the pain I
want to take with Bishop or pawn take
with pawn I'll take with Bishop almost
dropping the Queen there's such a funny
move Queen c7 98 okay okay he just loses
his queen after 98 his queen would have
to go back to be it okay so with some
nice opening successes from the light
side I think overall I've lost rating
points is tournament losing two games
that's too many
oh I just missed a sub I'm a singer 24
thanks for the sub I realized in the
chat and have the other window open
I appreciate that I could sack the
bishop mmm okay let's keep the bishop
it's a good Bishop and whites just like
up a full queen like black doesn't even
have a pawn for it so maybe he's just
crying right now doesn't want to resign
yeah opening files will be nice good
prima Brooke c1 okay somewhat of a
relaxing break don't need to exert too
much mental energy to finish this if
anyone has any questions I need rest
really the questions let me know in the
chat be happy to focus more on the chat
for the next minute or so okay we'll
take here Poliquin d4 check no worries
thanks for the content studying videos
include Sicilian won a game today
nice nice job yeah the close Sicilian
has has won a lot of people games but I
do appreciate that that comment and also
this expression rook a3 I think is gonna
be mates very very soon
I guess you could play Bishop c8 for
that
okay yeah he was praying for a miracle
that's God on that position
okay 67th place back on a streak
I'll just have time for a few more games
and I'm teaching an after-school chess
program today so can't spend the whole
day on me chess
well played five this game I don't think
I play d5 today might have six going for
the petrov ooh going for two nights by
g5 maybe mmm
fried liver somewhere in the world like
commoner is very excited but 94 tricky
line please play d6 common track he
castles castling can't be good because b
v g5 will fall can take this hitting the
Knights he defends in keto this this
Bishop should be pretty menacing take
drew 64 telling me to berserk
I can't piss irk if I'm a slowpoke like
slowpoke
being a slowpoke and boozer king it's
not a good combo I like to use my time
yeah I'm gonna just go for all wow King
side attack whew he plays g3 because now
the light squares are just very very
weak especially without his light
squared Bishop Queen f3 is a move
you also play queen G - I want to play
ff5 work a five there's a really cool
idea maybe it'll happen maybe I won't
find 92 here just like the only safe
square for the night
oh he doesn't wait what's going on here
I could just move my knight and then
this Knight is attacked and pinned
oh but it comes with check okay I don't
want to do that oh he wants to play -
six
I see so I'll just take first and then
between take me for oh I have a sneaky
move I'm gonna take and then Castle
queenside and he can't take back on d5
oh he takes his pawn okay that was
unexpected now just I got six blocks up
a piece okay now I can move slightly
more quickly I'll probably kingside
Castle have some pressure on that file
efore still a target we could trade
Queens I don't want to trade Queens Oh
like when you're up material there's a
couple options you can Dre down and
simplify or you can just attack your
opponent because you have more pieces
Bishop t4 uz4 is definitely a target
here I just want to take on c3 and take
on e4
let's do it I'll take with Knights it's
lots of pressure on f3 now but you
surviving kudos to him or her but it's
not going to last too long I still want
to trade Queens play Queen at six
okay this should be made very soon or
not
okay we'll trade Queens will try and
made him with just uh rook bishop in
pawns
I don't know if it's possible I correct
you to ph3 looks very close to me to
walk my king up oh there's this nice
move rook g1 and I think Bishop g4 is
unstoppable okay that was nice onon g5
helped out there good game going back to
tournaments oh I have to catch up to
crew 64 what place is he in he's an 11th
place is 66 points that's kind of out of
reach I have time for like one or two
more games maybe be all desert the next
game try and finish strong king of the
south die plateless guy today tonight
like just play this guy but I was white
Blizzard him I think that that was a
hippo game or no that wasn't might be
five game okay welp 85 he's playing
London he's playing my opening
and I'll cheer from San Diego Oh San
Diego California USA thank you very much
five hundred bits nice appreciate that a
Bishop e2 I play the London myself that
should be choose a very rare move in the
play Queen b6 b3 okay just going to
develop and then hopefully play quicker
than the previous games and the
structure is not great for whites if
this were a longer game I would try and
like just slowly massage his weaknesses
but because I've is irked and I have
less than a minute I might have to play
more aggressively but I'm gonna still
try to target his weaknesses c4 looks
like a great move because the C file
opens now the C pawns very very weak
rook c8 is coming
I'll probably just lose this pawn hello
what's his name again
oh yeah hello Jeremy long time no see
yeah lots of pressure building up yeah
this is a great position I'll fall and
this bishops doing nothing bring the
knight in probably to e4 its Mountain is
a rook you really get away with that
I'll take on me too I win the Knights
you should have played 96 and then my
Bishop and pawn would be attacked but
now I'm just up a piece so that's nice I
can play this
I think 29 seconds should be playing
enough time
maybe he'll play Bishop h2 or not so all
the pawns on the e-file but now it's
time to push them mmm
I can push push em baby there you go
uh and that's meat okay back to
tournaments triple pawns are three times
as good that's very true well the zerk
again wait I didn't want to play another
game
okay this is probably my last game we'll
make it a London well try and show how
the London is actually played they
should f5 we can change this and I'm
just gonna hold on to the pot so weird
scenario where oh he can't oh he can get
away with that okay very sneaky
we 95 I was gonna say it's one of the
scenarios where I can hold on but
nevermind Bradley is very excited for
the London 'if I've was a very good move
very good move
ouch I played before
probably not I'm gonna play it anyway
and try and confuse him
we'll take here okay
I forty-seven seconds left I don't like
buzzer King I don't know why I've assert
to play much quicker he's playing fast
too which is sort of good because he's
playing lower quality and my position
actually looks very reasonable now I'm
gonna start trying to push the a pong I
can have a good position earlier but he
should have taken some time to treat his
position well now I have two connected
passers will trade Queen III probably go
for b6 what do I do here Queen before I
guess turning b7 and also threatening g4
do this as pawns pins of the Queen yeah
White's winning a rook it's one of the
kind of deadly sins when your opponent
is uruk's you want to manage your time
but you don't want to play too quickly
okay oh no I hung a queen no I was
giving him advice life advice my hunger
Queen oh this is really bad oh man I
don't want to end with this game this
was really bad five thirteen seconds
left
how do I swindled him
G for not letting him meet me too easily
ah that move okay let's start tree
moving ah no okay that was so bad
what did I do I just hung a queen I was
so focused on like giving some practical
advice when it comes to loser king I
guess I unconsciously thought that he
would take with the rook and then I just
assumed my queen would be safe
uh oh but thank you for making me feel
better
Lucas for donating $5 slightly numbs the
pain of losing that game Queen take a
very good move actually because my
Queens attack I mean this is still just
crushing for a white I just have to do
this yeah I want I don't want to end
with that game but I have to go I'm
teaching chess today so thanks everyone
for watching
there's two more hours left there's not
going to be oh let me pause a treatment
before another game starts two hours
left
I'm so crossover keeping the pace but
yeah thanks guys for watching
I'll be back I might be back tomorrow
because tomorrow's protest League and my
team is playing the chess bras so there
might be a stream for that otherwise
I'll definitely be back on Thursday so
adios have a good day and good bye